this is maybe the most telling trumpian
moment a woman comes up to Trump to talk
to Trump about sergeant major Pat Payne
sergeant major Pat Payne is someone that
Trump awarded a medal of honor to in
2020 because Pat Payne was involved in
freeing 75 Isis held hostages okay
that's a fine totally reasonable thing
Trump seems visibly confused and asks
asks if Pat Payne died from war injuries
it's like no dude after he came back
from releasing the 75 hostages you gave
him the Medal of Honor do you think I
could look like that if you did me
absolutely
absolutely all those muscles and
everything else
away no he's actually currently still
alive did he pass away no no no he's
alive